- Alright everybody, that
you so much for coming out.
My name is Keith, and
I'm here from corporate
to talk about our office
relationship policy.
- It was these two. They
were the ones making whoopee.
- Oh yeah dude.
- I just want to say
that I made a mistake,
and I fully support the
ban on office romance.
- Well, actually there is no ban.
Believe it on not, yours
truly is in an office romance.
This is Kim, and we are in a fun,
and professional, relationship.
Isn't she the best? Look at that smile.
I miss her so much. (laughs)
I've been on the road for a week
doing this presentation, but
I am flying home tonight.
So Keith's Keys to a
successful office relationship.
Number one is Respect.
And respect not just for your co-lover,
but for your co-worker as well.
(coughing)
Yup, it sounds like we
struck a chord there.
Let's dive deeper into that, okay?
- Would that be deeper into
your relationship with...
- Kim.
- Kim! Right.
- Great idea, let's use an example.
So Kim's assistant, Jaime,
came to us a year ago
because he was feeling uncomfortable
with setting up our dinner reservations.
So we started handling it ourselves.
- Oh no!
- No no no, don't worry because we were,
say it with me now, respectful.
- [All] Respectful...
- And now Kim's professional
relationship with Jaime
is stronger than ever, I promise you that.
So, moving on to number
two of Keith's Keys.
- Keith!
- I know what you guys are gonna say,
and it's an intentional typo.
- Great typo Keith. Question?
- Yeah.
- What role does communication have in,
say, an office breakup?
- Well, I've never been part of
a failed office relationship,
so I don't know.
- Hypothetically.
Well, I'd be devastated.
I would have trouble finding
light in this dark, dark world.
But luckily, that will never happen to me.
- Oh my god.
- She's miraculous, isn't she?
She is my everything, only second to
Loafie, here. (laughs)
(all groaning)
- No!
- Don't worry, I'm gonna
continue the presentation
right after I get an eyeful of
my best friend in the entire world.
- Caylen, I still love you!
- I knew it!
- See?
Keith's Keys can lead to a
successful office relationship.
- Great job, Keith! Mission accomplished.
I'll see you out.
- Actually, I have
dozens more Keith's Keys.
- Well no need, because you were
able to repair Caylen and Anna's
disgusting mistake of a relationship.
So let's give Keith a round of applause!
- (applause) Yeah. Really good, yeah.
- Thank you so much!
- Thank you!
(laughs)
Oh, I'm blowing up! (laughs)
(door slams)
What?
No! (screams in agony)
- Do you think he knows? Or...
(lighthearted music)
- Let's just wait it out.
- We can move into my place.
- No.
- It's a big van.
(laughter)